[Musique]
bonjour je plaide la rue bonjour moïse
sur le tombeau jour aux auditeurs de
marc vivien secrétaire général de la
ligue de football de la martinique merci
d'être dense arcady dans moins d'une
semaine sur quadv arue la sélection de
martinique sera dans sa coupe des
nations de la terre arrive on espère une
qualification face à curaçao ce sera
jeudi prochain lors de la 2ème finale
et puis ensuite affronter le vainqueur
de jamaïque et guyane giotto de la rue
la martinique
notre pays joue gros en terme sportif en
terme d'image en termes d'organisation
face à la caraïbe du football bien sûr
cette compétition est un enjeu majeur
pour le football un ticket mais
également pour la martinique 1 puisque
il y avoue delà de l'enjeu sportif un
enjeu de représentation du pays
martinique nous tous les pays de la
caraïbe de la concacaf auront le regard
tourné la semaine prochaine vers la
martinique
donc nous nous devons de réussir à tous
les niveaux comment ces autres nations
de la caraïbe repart quand même de pays
comme trinidad comme la jamaïque haïti
qui ont déjà participé à une coupe du
monde commence et qui nous regardent nos
martinique nous antilles guyane
française mais je crois que depuis
quelques années ces pays nous regardent
avec beaucoup de respect
il est vrai que ces pays c'est quand
même un mépris par froid parce que nous
n'étions pas une nation indépendante
je ne dirais pas à mes prix aujourd'hui
je dirais pour rester positif avec
beaucoup de respect respect sur le plan
sportif lorsque la martinique a démontré
qu'avec les petits moyens dont elle
disposait elle avait toujours faire jeu
égal avec ses grandes nations de la
caraïbe et savent respecter sportivement
ah oui tout à fait
enfin d'un point de vue sportif nous
sommes respectés et puis je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes respectés
d'un point de vue politique nous avons
acquis une légitimité au sein de deux
organes de la concacaf de l'acf fut
d'ailleurs genre aux preuves
aujourd'hui la place de maurice victoire
qui est membre du conseil de la concacaf
alors les matinées neuf sont
actuellement en stage à marie galante
ils vont rentrer en martinique mardi
prochain alors sportivement
doit-on très doit-on être inquiète quand
on sait que tous les joueurs espérés ne
sont pas la cause des de certains clubs
européens professionnels qui se sont
montrés réticents à les libérer pouvoir
jouer avec la sélection de martinique
alors déjà un petit point d'explication
les matinino quand va-t-il dans des
bâtiments des au pluriel
oui non concernant la préparation de
notre sélection elle se fait normalement
avec les moyens dont nous disposons il
faut dire qu'aujourd'hui
donc nous avons l'apport de quelques
joueurs professionnels qui avaient
l'habitude d'évoluer avec nous il ya une
dizaine sur 23 voilà il est vrai que par
rapport à nos ambitions
nous n'avons pas réussi à faire ce que
nous voulions le constat est là
aujourd'hui il faut déjà se tourner vers
la compétition est fait avec le groupe
dont nous disposons corner que l'igp à
fédération ce dossier d'adhésion à la
fifa la fédération internationale de
football comme le demande la martinique
est également la guadeloupe et en guyane
ça restera lettre morte et dossier
définitivement enterrée a pas du tout
pas du tout vous avez bien raison de
dire que c'est un dossier commun avec
les ligue antilles guyane
deuxièmement c'est pas du tout un
dossier qu'est ce qu'il a dit laura
flessel la nouvelle ministre des sports
c'est un dossier aujourd'hui que nous
avons relancé d'accord nous avons
attendu donc l'élection du nouveau
comité exécutif de la fédération il ya
eu les élections
dernièrement et ce dossier nous l'avons
relancé puisque les trois lignes sur son
gril unis déjà deux fois dans le premier
semestre de 2010 est pour relancer ce
dossier il y mettre en place une
nouvelle stratégie avec une nouvelle
ministre effectivement qui arrivent et
quadeloupéens elle sait ce que ça peut
représenter
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle a déjà été
sensibilisés s'est déjà prononcé là
dessus écoutez on ne sait pas encore ce
qu'elle dit tout ce que je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui c'est que nous l'avons
déjà sollicité pas là puisque nos avions
envoyé à sept ministres une demande de
rendez-vous pour samedi dernier
malheureusement ce rendez vous n'a pas
pu avoir lieu mais en tout cas nous
espérons bientôt la rencontrer et lui
exposer nos motifs et et nos ambitions
sur ce dossier donc le dossier des
pandores financièrement premier contrat
cette 25e coupe des nations de la
caraïbe
globalement on peut dire que la
compétition va coûter entre 280 et 990
millions au budget bouclé pas bouclée
puisque il ya une part variable celle
des spectateurs que nous arrêter ça
nombreux les sponsors de jeu la
collectivité territoriale barclays
précieux les principaux bailleurs de
fonds sont la collectivité territoriale
de martinique l'état la 7e bière légère
baisse légère hausse ce qu'on dit et le
non dit qu'il ya tellement difficultés
de la part des collectivités moi je vous
dis au budget constant puisque je vous
dis on va dévoiler les chiffres 1 nous
avons obtenu l'anc 145 1000 euros
concernant le plan d'action régional
montant similaire à ce que nous avons pu
en dernière et pour l'organisation de la
compétition coupe des nations de la
caraïbe des préparations à la gold cup
nous avons montant global de 170
millions suffisant suffisant toujours
insuffisant puisque voilà mais il faut
qu'on fasse avec et c'est ce que nous
avons fait
comment voyez vous cette coupe des
nations de la caraïbe il faut la gagner
ou bien considérer juste comme disons un
bonne préparation en vue de cette gold
cup qui aura lieu aux états unis du 7 au
26 juillet vannes à dire elle accède
ball club c'est notre coupe du monde à
nous notre coupe du monde de football à
nous nos sa clique
non l'objectif concernant la coupe des
nations de la caraïbe c'est clairement
de gagner cette compétition a d'autant
plus que ce sera la dernière édition de
la coupe des nations de la caraïbe qui
l'année prochaine se jouera sous un
autre format y sera organisée par la
concacaf
donc l'objectif clairement c'est de
gagner cette compétition et est-ce
qu'elles sont une quatrième fois au
palmarès exactement cette coupe
cette école que cette coupe des nations
de la caraïbe ce sont des éléments
moteurs pour les jeunes martiniquais
pour les licenciés pour le public mais
il faut que ce soit un élément moteur
de toutes les difficultés que nous
rencontrons sur le plan financier pour
organiser la préparation de la sélection
je crois qu il faut sur le dire il faut
que tous les martiniquais soient
conscients que nous ne sommes pas
aujourd'hui dans les meilleures
conditions sportives ne serait ce que
par rapport aux joueurs que nous
souhaitions avoir et sur lesquels nous
avons obtenu 10 au refuge qu'est ce que
je voulais vous poser est ce que des
martiniquais ceux qui sont dans l'élite
du football au françois à saint joseph
mais aussi les autres clubs qui sont
peut-être un peu moins médiatisé
est ce que tous ses licenciés dès le
mois de septembre se disent j'ai
peut-être une carte à jouer en sélection
et je veux aller dans cette ville que je
veux aller dans cette coupe des nations
de la caraïbe où ils se disent la porte
est déjà fermé parce qu'on fera appel à
des professionnels pas du tout écouter
lors du dernier match contre trinidad il
y avait neuf joueurs locaux chan ting
donc j'espère que tout jeune joueur
martiniquais aspire un jour à devenir
professionnel la nasa cette envie là
ressentez cet avis auprès des jeunes
licenciés tout à fait tout à fait motivé
tout à fait quand on va dans les clubs
quand on écoute les jeunes écoutaient
lors de la semaine dernière les finales
de jeunes à georges nation je passe si
vous avez vous imaginé avec plus de
monde que lors d'un match de deux
divisions de jeunes à l'une des ces
chaînes il reste quoi il reste de
ronaldo didier survient sans nous bien
sûr ils vont arriver bien sûr de ronaldo
avant de dériver de la sélection
pratique c'est évident donc voilà c'est
comme tout jeune de la planète c'est par
la sélection se trouve dans la porte
bien sûr alors on n'a pas eu de l'accord
de paix et de cette coupe des nations de
terrible non on y reviendra jusqu'au
match de jeudi prochain
la saison se termine jean claude larue
globalement comment se portent les clubs
de martinique on va pas parler du golden
rien ne m'a pas parlé du club
franciscain parce que ce sont des gros
morceaux comme on dit mais les autres
jusqu en régionale 3 est ce que les
clubs globalement sont en bonnes sorties
les clubs sont en très grande difficulté
il est en très grande souffrance
pourquoi et ça a fait l'objet du projet
nouveau comité directeur et nouvelle
évolution orientation 2020 tout
simplement parce que l'éclosion en
souffrance parce qu'il ya un manque de
bénévoles
il ya un manque de moyens financiers que
l'activité sera devant des milliers de
ses se retire de plus en plus il faut
pas tout le temps mettre ça sur le dos
jets de dés des collectivités il ya
aussi les partenaires privés qui ne joue
très rarement le jeu voilà il y a
aujourd'hui donc on mendie source de
manque de finances dr des frais
structures qui sont aujourd'hui
complètement obsolète et qui ne donne
pas envie à pratiquer le sport
donc il ya un certain nombre d'éléments
jouent du typhon que les clubs sont très
très grande aux comptes
et pourtant les parents amènent leurs
enfants à l'école de football du
mercredi après midi du samedi
et pourtant oui nos clients mais nous
avons toujours dix mille licenciés dans
huit mille jeunes mais malgré cela il
faut qu'on se penche très rapidement et
on a commencé à le faire ont trouvé des
solutions à apporter des réponses au
club on a commencé à le faire sur la
partie financière puis ce qu'on a fait
lors de la dernière assemblée générale
une modification de la répartition des
recettes à dire qu'aujourd'hui le club
qui accueille gare de 75 % de la recette
héros via sur le sol à au club visiteur
on a aussi une modification dans la rue
les droits de mutation des jeunes
aujourd'hui à compter de cette saison où
les clubs formateurs vont récupérer une
part des droits de mutation à pays par
le club accueillant donc un certain
nombre de mesures que nous essayons de
mettre en place pour aider les clubs et
puis il ya également des dotations en
équipements que nous faisons grâce à la
fédération française de football vers
lille pourrait être mieux c'était la
fisa silva nombre de la fifa a bien
évidemment bien évidemment écoutez je
vous donne un chiffre aujourd'hui ne
serait ce qu'avec la concacaf sur le
programme one concacaf programme de
développement du football sur la
formation les infrastructures et là nous
touchons annuellement tous les pays de
la concacaf touche 200 milles de la côte
est aujourd'hui s'il fallait faire un
comparatif entre les sommes touchées par
la faite par la ligue de football entre
la fédération française et la concacaf
aujourd'hui les réel déséquilibre avec
un autre indicateur est ce que les
centres de formation des équipes
professionnelles françaises
viennent rechercher des joueurs chez
nous ça c'est un indicateur vrai
indicateur régulièrement régulièrement
vous en avez un actuellement en
martinique le stade rennais au stade de
rennes qui va signer un partenariat avec
un club local freinage avait décidé des
clubs professionnels qui organise
régulièrement des centres de détection
alors en tunique
le martiniquais le jeune martiniquais
formés ici ne coûte pas trop cher ou six
clubs donc nos jeunes martiniquais
nous ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
les jeunes partent dans de bonnes
conditions
et puis pas trop tôt voilà donc il faut
aujourd'hui que nous mettions en oeuvre
les conditions pour faire notre propre
formation ici merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup sur toi de bienvenue secrétaire
général de football nous donne rendez
vous jeudi prochain face à carros à
houplin demi-finale de la coupe des
nations à creil bonne journée merci
[Musique]